vous êtes le seul policier qui tient ce
discours où vous ne condamnez pas ce qui
est en train de se passer justement
comme le désarmement psychologique
actuel de la police est à dire que si
c'est comme aller jusqu'à 36 ans la
police me suis d'accord mais c'est pas
pour autant que vous détenez la vérité à
deux ou pas d'accord avec vous est ce
parce qu'arabes et gérer vos collègues
vos collègues disent qu'on a désarmé
psychologiquement la police parce qu'on
leur a enlevé des moyens d'agir là parce
qu'on remet en cause la police sur les
problèmes remet en cause la police sur
leurs techniques d'intervention ont
remis en cause la police sans cesse sur
l'histoire de violence que de ce côté on
a donné toute la défense mais on
attendait ça c'est de la politique
politicienne et des t bonds colas n'a
pas on a pas le même vous connais pas
regardé par les atouts vos collègues
disent le contraire devant ne peut pas
ne pas avoir un discours vous êtes une
politique et je suis un nombre de
numéros se passe sans problème il ya une
évolution de la société qui me paraît
indiscutable c'est que la violence a
monté d'un cran s'en était avant a oui
un échange de mots ce à dire une
altercation
ce qui était une altercation ça devient
une bagarre ce qui était une bagarre ça
devient un massacre je ne sais pas c'est
ça il y avait la police tandis qu'elle
arrive mais quand elle arrive le type il
s'est déjà fait massacrer ou yuan s'est
déjà fait massacrer donc c'est un
problème de société c'est un problème
d'éducation pouvait mettre deux fois
plus de flics n'y aura pas un flic
derrière que tu as fait chaque agression
donc ce n'est pas la peine d'en faire un
débat politique à mon avis c'est
complètement hors sujet sarko et des
autres on s'en fout c'est lévy mails
comment on répond avec des moyens autres
que la police qui ne peut pas tout faire
à cette montée de la violence qui est
encore aggravée voir l'ambiance autour
de la coved vaud eric doit 3 harper vous
dites oui vers moi parce que je constate
comme chacun parce que je prends le
métro parce que je marche beaucoup que
dès qu'il ya un problème ça prend une
tournure très inquiétante avec de
l'ultra violence qui n'existait pas
avant
avant les gens s'insultaient et chacun
reprenait son chemin maintenant ils se
battent le type dans la laverie fait une
réflexion l'autre revient avec ses potes
et des bâtards justement ce qu'on a on a
les extrêmes se montrer ces images on a
tous vu on va les rencontrer regardé
c'était le doute
[Rires]
[Musique]
alors ça c'était dans une laverie un
père de famille avait demandé les
personnes de porter le masque dans la
laverie et à un garçon il est revenu
avec d une équipe derrière avec donc
d'aider des coups de batte de baseball
c'est vrai que l'épidémie aggrave encore
ce film et c'est ça que les gens sont
nerveux et maintenant le masque donne
lieu à des tas d'incidents et parfois
datchy